hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible
Q&A I'm Jason Bradley and I'm so glad
that you've decided to join us because
this is going to be a learning
experience we're going to break bread
together and I want to share this
scripture with you it's taken from
Romans chap
15:4 it says for whatever things were
written before were written for our
learning that we through the patience
and comfort of the scriptures might have
hope if you're looking for hope today
well you are in the right place because
we'll be going to the word of God for
the answers to questions that you have
submitted and if you haven't submitted
your questions well I want to share with
you how you can do that you can text
your questions to 618 228
3975 again that's 618 228
3975 or you can email your questions to
Bible QA 3abn.org
at
3abn.org that's 3abn uncore official let
me introduce to you the panel that we
have that will be answer or the panelist
that will be answering your questions we
have Pastor James raferty it's great to
have you good to be here with you Jason
Daniel John looking forward to these
questions and the answers from the word
of God that that's right and next to you
we have Pastor lomma Kang Pastor lomma
Kang it's great to have you here with
yes I tell you you know time and
distance doesn't matter I'm glad that
James is joining us from another world
away but it's going to be fun James and
John the sons of thunder love it love it
and then next to you we have the
professor professor parin not a son of
Thunder I guess but we'll still be
brothers so it's good to be here good to
open up the word of God amen amen would
you pray for us I'd love to thank you
dear father in Heaven Lord You' promised
us that you've given us everything we
need for life and godliness we know you
fulfill that promise through what you've
given us in the word of God and as we
open it up today we ask for your Holy
Spirit to fill us to guide our minds and
our thinking and Center our thoughts on
you your word and your truth and we
thank you for fulfilling what you have
promised in jesus' name amen amen amen
thank you Pastor RAF this question comes
to you it's says Revelation
16:15 is symbolic spoken by Jesus as it
is recorded and read why is the rest of
the chapter not symbolic this is from
Rod out of
Idaho great question Rod thank you for
that question out of Idaho William
Miller uh a Baptist Minister set forth
some basic biblical principles for Bible
study and of course he was the one who
heralded the coming of Christ in 1844
the millerite movement and was a deest
at one time but really went back and and
studied the word of God and learned how
to study Bible uh the Bible and Bible
prophecy and in these principles He
suggests one of the ways we can deal
with bible verses to identify whether
they're literal or symbolic and he says
that in uh the Bible verse as we go
through the Bible verses verse by verse
in the Bible verse we need to ascertain
the symbolism by determining if the
verse we're reading makes good sense as
it stands and does no violation to the
basic laws of nature so if the verse
makes sense as it reads doesn't violate
the laws of nature it should be
understood literally um but if it
doesn't make sense and it does violate
the laws of of nature the simple laws of
nature then we should be understanding
it symbolically and of course uh we can
go into a whole study on how to unlock
those symbols so with this in mind this
principle in mind let's read Revelation
16 and let's just read verses 12-6 I
know you referred to verse 15 but let's
just read the surrounding verses and try
to understand if they're symbolic or
literal okay verse 12 the six Angel
poured out his V vial upon the great
river Euphrates and the water thereof
was dried up that the way of the kings
of the East might be prepared and I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs come
out of the mouth of the dragon and out
of the mouth of the Beast now the mouth
of the false prophet for they are the
spirits of devils working miracles and
and going forth unto the kings of the
earth and of the whole world to gather
them to the Battle of that great day of
God Almighty verse 15 your verse behold
I come as a thief blessed is he that WTH
and keepeth his garments lest he walk
naked and they see his shame and then
verse 16 and he gathered them together
into a place called in the Hebrew tongue
Armageddon now as we apply Miller's
principles of understanding symbolism in
Prophecy we can see that Revel 16 is
largely literal as you've suggested I
mean if you look at the whole chapter we
didn't look at the whole chapter uh but
we can also see that uh Christ's
returning as a thief and the need to
hold on to these garments of Salvation
is quite literal so the verse you're
referring to is actually very literal
Christ is going to be coming as a thief
and we need to hold on to the garments
of Salvation now verses 12 and 13 and
specific spefically verse 13 are really
more symbolic they describe frogs coming
out of the mouth of the Beast and out of
the mouth of a false prophet and out of
the mouth of a dragon and that
definitely does violence to the basic
laws of nature and it doesn't really Mak
sense as it reads so those would be the
verses that we would seek to understand
the meaning based on a symbolic
interpretation and now if you'd like a
more detailed study on symbolism in
prophecy and and how to study these
symbols uh you can go to our Dare To
Dream Channel Jason 3abn D to dream
Channel and you can watch salvation in
symbols and signs and in that we break
down the principles of prophetic
interpretation in more detail and you
could even uh email us and ask for a
digital copy of a study on Armageddon
and also ask for William Miller's
principles of biblical interpretation so
Rod I hope that's helped to answer your
question of course if you have more uh
question about this uh be sure and get a
hold of us and we can do some followup
with you amen amen well said uh and I
love the plug for dare to dream there uh
you can go to 3abn plus. TV and you can
watch salvation and symbols and signs on
3abn plus as well uh Pastor LMA Kang can
a demon talk to
me in a in a nutshell let's start with
Genesis chapter 3 Genesis 3:1 from the
beginning Satan spoke he spoke through a
serpent so let's look at what the Bible
teaches Genesis 3:1 now the serpent was
more cunning than any beast of the field
which the Lord God had made and he said
to the woman has God indeed said You
shall not eat of every tree of the
garden so there was a conversation
taking place between the woman Eve and
the serpent in Daniel and Revelation
12:9 calls that Serpent of all the devil
and Satan describes him as a fallen
angel a demon today as we would or the
head of all the demons the Devil Himself
and then you find Genesis 3:4 and the
serpent said to the woman there's a
conversation taking place here now we
know he wasn't there in physical form
like looking like a person with wings
but he was channeling through the
serpent but we now go to um The Book of
Mark Mark 1 verse 34 speaking about
how demons communicated with Jesus then
he healed many who were sick with
various diseases and cast out many
demons and he did not allow the demons
to speak because they knew him so demons
can speak Jesus
said don't say it and he cast the demons
out because they wanted to protest and
they protested they said to him have you
come to torment us before our time time
and they were talking about the Lake of
Fire where the Beast and the false
prophets the devil and his angels all
will be cast into the lake of fire then
Luke
4:41 and demons also came out of many
crying out and saying you are the Christ
the son of the Living God right again
right away once again we see the demons
are speaking they're they're
acknowledging the fact that Jesus is the
Christ the son of God so evil spirits
can communicate Isaiah 8:1 19 says says
and when they say to you seek those who
are mediums and wizards who whisper and
mutter whispering and muttering can be
best understood as speaking softly and
murmuring
complaining it says and um should not a
people seek their God should they seek
the dead on behalf of the living so you
see that once again Whisperers and
mutters these were people that were
mediums that said you can communicate
with your dead loved ones but these were
demon speaking and I had a call from a
young man once who said he saw his
mother in his room talking to him I said
next time you see her say this that's
not your mother that's a demon and the
Bible talks about what form they in
these are what the Bible calls familiar
spirits Leviticus 19:31 give no regard
to mediums and familiar spirits why
familiar from which we get the word
family the devil takes on the form of
grandma or uncle and he shows up and
says hey Jason it's been a while how's
things going I want I want you to know
Heaven is great just sending a message
from God he's going to let you know that
he's coming in two weeks and people come
out with these strange things and they
say well where'd you get that from well
my mother told me that's not your mom
that's not your loved one that's a
familiar Spirit a demon channeling
through this medium and that's what
happened to Saul in 1st Chronicles 10:13
so Saul died for his transgressions
which he committed against the Lord even
against the word of the Lord which he
kept not also for asking counsel from
one that had a familiar Spirit to
inquire of it so what happened when when
he saw a familiar spirit that he thought
was Samuel the prophet he began
conversing and that evil spirit
condemned Saul now we know it wasn't
Samuel because if the reality of it is
we know the living know that they will
die but the dead know nothing
Ecclesiastes 9 verse 5 and six so that
was not Samuel talking to Saul and
furthermore a witch conjured up this
evil spirit to bring Saul to the point
of his ultimate rejection of God and he
died for communicating with an evil
spirit amen they can't communicate well
said we have no reason to be deceived
because we have the word of God that's
right and so if we study it out there
there's no reason for us to be deceived
thank you for that answer uh Daniel can
you please explain Proverbs 16 verse4
this is from Michaela out of Tennessee
all right thank you Michaela for asking
this question Proverbs
16:4 says in the new King James version
that I'm reading the Lord has made all
for himself yes even the wicked for the
day of
Doom so looking at this text either it
tells us a very terrible truth that
doesn't line up with the rest of
scripture that God not only made the
wicked to be Wicked but made them for
the purpose of destroying them either
that or we're misunderstanding the text
and we need to look deeper into the
language and that's what we're going to
do here I'm going to look at that word
for himself the Lord has made all for
himself and the Hebrew word is
M and the literal idea of that word the
meaning of that word is to answer or to
respond we find that verse that word in
a number of different places twice in
the Book of Job where Eli who is
dissatisfied with the answers of the
other friends five times in Proverbs for
example Proverbs 15:1 a soft answer
turns away wrath and that's that same
Hebrew word in the same chapter Proverbs
161 the preparations of the heart belong
to man but the answer of the tongue uh
is from the Lord and that's the same
verse there so a better way of
understanding this text is that God has
made all things to answer to the
unchangeable order of cause and effect
in other words sin is ultimately going
to be followed by the effect which is
the day of Doom which is the day of
Destruction so let's take this verse
another way God has made every person
with the power to choose and that Power
of Choice then is going to lead to the
Natural response of either life or death
and so this text actually is an
assurance to us that God has given us
the power of choice and that God has
given the assurance that sin is not
going to last forever no sinner can
outsmart the consequence es of sin and
perpetuate its destruction into eternity
God has given everybody the power to
choose and that choice is going to have
a final result and so we find this
reflected in a couple of other Bible
translations and let me read them to you
uh The New American Standard Bible takes
Proverbs 16:4 and says the Lord has made
everything for its own purpose even the
wicked for the day of evil the Amplified
Bible the Lord has made everything for
its own purpose even the wicked
according to their role for the day of
evil then The New International Version
says the Lord works out everything to
its proper end even the wicked for a day
of disaster so putting together what we
understand from the Hebrew words and and
taking a look at other Bible
translations especially I actually went
to the avenus Bible commentary on this
so you can see that there's different
tools that you can use it reveals how to
understand this verse great breakdown
thank you Daniel uh pastor rafy we come
to you with this one is Romans 8:
18-23 talking about the animals this is
from K out of
Texas thank you for your question Kay
let's begin by taking a look at the text
in Romans chapter 8 starting with Verse
18 Paul says for I reckon that the
sufferings of this present time are not
worthy to be compared with the glory
that shall be revealed in us for the
earnest expectation of the creature
waits for the manifestation of the sons
of God for the creature was made subject
sub to vanity not willingly but by
reason of him who has subjected the same
in Hope because the creature itself also
shall be delivered from the bondage of
corruption into the Glorious Liberty of
the children of God for we know that the
whole creation groans and travails in
pain together until now and not only
they but ourselves also which have the
first fruits of the spirit even we
ourselves grown within ourselves waiting
for the adoption to wit the Redemption
of our body so the key word here is the
word creature and creation it's actually
the same Greek word used four times in
these verses it's talking about God's
original creation which would include
the animals but not
exclusively be talking about the animals
so the word creature comes from the
strongs 2936 it means original formation
or by implication the thing that was
literally or figuratively created or
formed now the following verses would
support that the animals would be
included in the Redemption that is
mentioned in Romans 8: 18-23 so God is
in Romans chapter 8 he's talking about
the Redemption of the entire creation
and if you look in Isaiah 11: 6-9 you're
going to see that that Redemption
includes the animals the animals are
part of God's original creation but then
of course if you look in second Peter
chapters chapter 3: 9-13 you're going to
find that that red Redemption is not
only including the animals but it also
includes creation itself this world uh
the trees the mountains the The Meadows
the waters the flower everything God
created is going to be redeemed and
we're told in second Peter 39-13 there's
going to be a new Heaven and a new Earth
and all creation is waiting for that God
is waiting in second Peter 3 God is
actually waiting for us for the sons of
men we can we are privileged to hasten
the coming of Jesus Christ but that
hastening can only take place as Jesus
says in Matthew 24:14 when the gospel is
preached to all the world as a witness
to All Nations then God can bring the
end all of the crisis that that aligns
every human being either with God or
against God and he can bring a summation
to all this a conclusion of all of this
and then according to Revelation 21:1
there can be a new heavens and a new
Earth and the first first heavens and
the first first Earth are going to be
passed away and there's going to be no
more pain no more sorrow no more crying
Isaiah 65:22 also shares this so yes K
Romans 81 18-23 is talking about the
animals but not exclusive the animals as
the word creature refers to God's
original creation which includes the
animals but is much broader and
inclusive of all that God originally
formed or created amen amen thank you
Pastor raffy Pastor LMA Kang Ben wants
to know when we grieve the holy Spirit
does he depart from us how do we know
that we grieved him and how do we get
him back okay well Ben I just want to
encourage you for asking the question
because if you ask the question if
that's a concern that you might have you
wouldn't be asking this question if you
grieve the Holy Spirit let's start with
Matthew 12 and verse 32 anyone who
speaks a word against the son of man it
will be forgiven him but whoever speaks
against the holy spirit will not be
forgiven him either in this age or in
the age age to come you know grieving
the holy spirit is not a singular act
it's a continual process uh I'll give
you an example if my mom called me and I
said and I didn't answer you know what
there's something called the the law of
um
familiarity what happens is after a
while my my ear Tunes her out it's
like just that's why people could live
in front of a train an overhead train in
New York and you know that in New York
they have these trains that are outside
and these trains we go visit somebody
and the whole house is rumbling and
they're sitting there calm as ever they
don't hear a single thing we don't pay
attention when I was in Trinidad a
number of years ago about 5:30 in the
morning I heard these you know the the
call for worship among the Muslims and
it scared the life out of me and I call
911 only to realize they don't have a
911 in Trinidad so I called the police
department I said I was just they said
it's normal just get used to it and the
people that own the house they said we
don't even hear it any longer see what
happens when you tune out the voice of
God that's where the process of grieving
the spirit of God comes in for example
you have in the Bible Saul grieved the
spirit of God 1st Samuel
16:14 but the spirit of the Lord
departed from Saul and the evil spirit
from the Lord troubled him so when Saul
became so wicked that he would no longer
listen to The Guiding voice of God as
the spirit of God impressed upon him the
Lord said well as it says in 2
Thessalonians 2:8 because you receive
not a love of the truth that you might
be saved God will send a strong delusion
so another Spirit took over and we know
the end of Paul's story also King David
when he had been asking for Redemption
asking for forgiveness notice his prayer
Psalm
51:11 cast me not away from thy presence
and do not take your Holy Spirit from me
he thought man killed Uriah had
an affair with baseba impregnated her
I've lost my Integrity I've lost my
standing before god what have you do
don't take your Holy Spirit from me and
we know David was so completely redeemed
that later on he uses he used him as an
example to his son and said if you walk
as David did and keep my Commandments
that David did and Solomon probably said
wait a minute which David are you
talking God can completely redeem so
here's the point why is grieving the
holy spirit so important why is this
something you should never do the holy
spirit is one that convicts us of sin if
you no longer hear the convicting voice
of God you have grieved the Holy Spirit
well said praise God for Redemption
Redemption that's right chances Daniel
in Genesis 1: 27 God created man in his
own image male and female in Genesis 2:7
the Lord God formed man of the Dust of
the ground were there two creations of
man this is from Esther out of Canada
all right thank you Esther and this is a
good question here let me make some
comparisons between Genesis 1 and two
Genesis 1 is Cosmic in scope you have
heavens and earth sun moon and stars
patterns of time ecosystems that sustain
life categories of a plant kingdom and
an animal kingdom looking above from a a
a grand perspective the big picture
Genesis 2 is very much more personal
dealing with God's interaction with
Humanity Genesis 1 tells us in panoramic
fashion what God created an environment
into which he placed man Genesis 2 Zooms
in this close-up portrait enhancing the
detail of how God placed man in this
environment Genesis 1 tells us that God
formed Humanity in His image Genesis 2
tells us the way that he did it Formed
them out of the Dust of the earth
breathed into his nostrils the Breath of
Life Genesis 1 tells them us that God
made man man male and female and that
they should reproduce and Genesis 2 then
shows us how he did that he took a rib
from Adam's side and made the woman and
brought them together in marriage
Genesis 1 tells us that God made
Humanity male and female Genesis 2 then
gives us their names Adam and Eve man
and woman Genesis 1 tells us that they
had dominion over the animals and
Genesis 2 then gets personal it says how
that Dominion was to be enacted they
name the Animals Adam names the animals
one by one to care for them As a
caretaker Dominion is not something to
have power and authority and dominion
and might over but to care for Genesis 1
tells us that God gave food through
nature Genesis 2 then tells how he did
it says care for the garden uh and eat
of the trees that I have given you
specifically the ones that I instruct
you to eat from in other words Genesis
one and two are the same story it's one
story told from different perspectives
one from the big picture that's Genesis
1 and Genesis 2 gets really close to see
how God interacts with us now just
really quickly here you might have a
question about Genesis 2 verse 5 that
says that Genesis 2 happened uh before
there was any plant of the field or herb
of the field before there was any rain
or man to till the ground I'm not going
to answer that whole text there but I
want to let you know that on the website
3abn Bible anwers.com under the category
of creation there's an answer to that
text and the the short version of it is
all those things just mentioned that
plant of the field herb of the field
Rain Man to till the ground are all a
result of sin because this story was
written down after the flood it was
written down after sin reminding us that
when God created the world originally
there were no effects of the of sin that
we see around us right now so you
wouldn't say God made this mess here no
all of the mess comes as a result of sin
mm amen you know one thing that I
learned on salvation in symbols and
signs was the whole repeat and enlarged
theme that's seen throughout the Bible
um I know that we may have some viewers
at home and some listeners that are
sitting there with a burning desire to
get their question answered and you're
wondering well how can I submit my
question if you're just now joining us I
want to share with you how you can send
your question in you can send it to 618
228 3975 again text us at 6182280065
official and we would love to answer
those questions from the word of God in
future programs Pastor rafy in
Jeremiah 5:4 God says he knew him before
he formed him in the belly that being
said will the aborted get
resurrected great question uh God yes
God does say that he knows each child in
the belly and so God himself self knows
who is going to be in heaven and what
the future of each human being is and we
can have a lot of assurance uh that God
will save children especially The Unborn
um God knows every baby and whether or
not that the baby could be saved even
though they were aborted and in his
wisdom he will save every child that can
be in heaven and respond uh to his grace
and to his love and since God knows them
in the belly there must be something or
someone to know now I'm just putting a
little you know a little something out
there to understand how important it is
uh that we recognize that life begins at
conception and not uh after a baby is
actually brought forth from the womb um
it can't be just a blob of tissue this
text tells us that babies in the utero
are known and can be known and therefore
they're human beings before birth
they're children before birth in fact in
the Bible new testament old testament um
children well at least in the New
Testament the word for a child that's
born and the word for a baby in the in
the belly is the same word uh so of
course the entire Bible supports this
reality and uh 3abn actually has a book
coming out uh very soon uh on the issue
of abortion and life and you can look
for that it's a book that you'll want to
get ah hold of but let's just look at
what the Bible says in Isaiah chapter
49: 24 and 25 the Bible says this shall
the prey be taken from the mighty or the
lawful captive delivered but thus sayith
the Lord even the captives of the mighty
shall be taken away and the prey of the
terrible shall be delivered for I will
contend with him that contends with thee
and I will save thy children now this
verse is a promise and it's especially
for children these are bible promises
that we can claim for children as and
for The Unborn children uh Jeremiah 31:
15 to1 17 says thus sayth the Lord a
voice was heard in Rama lamentation and
bitter weeping Rachel weeping for her
children who refuse to be comforted for
her children because they are not thus
says the Lord refrain thy voice from
weeping and thine eyes from tears for
thy Work shall be rewarded says the Lord
and they shall come again from the land
of the enemy and there is hope in thine
hand says the Lord that thy children
shall come again to their own border so
yes God will resurrect children that
have been been aborted and perhaps
parents who have repented will have the
opportunity to raise these children in
heaven now we don't know how many
children who have been aborted would be
raised by God Only God knows that but he
can save children who've been aborted
and and if parents repent they could
even raise those children but if not
angels of God are assigned to every
child and they will have that privilege
according to Matthew 18:10 so I hope
this is helpful in answering your
question yes I'm I'm glad you answered
that you know I just had a child and I
had a little girl and going to those
ultrasounds and seeing the different
stages you know where she's resting in
her mother's womb and she has her her
hand on her head or her little legs
crossed through different things she's
doing these different
movements you know there's life in the
womb it's not just a a clump of tissue
So yeah thank you for that uh Pastor
lomma Kang the Bible me mentions hell
but during creation hell was not created
what is or where is Hell okay very very
good question and I'm thankful that you
brought that out you know Matthew makes
it very clear that hell was prepared for
the devil and his angels and I'll give
you the scripture in just a moment here
so in the beginning you have uh in the
English language we have one word hell
but in the Hebrew and Greek there are
numerous words that describe the various
conditions uh one describes the grave
the other describes a place of Torment
the Lake of Fire and the Bible makes it
very clear when these conditions exist
now the grave is something that is the
result of you know Romans 5 and verse2
as in Adam all die well that's 1
Corinthians 15:22 but through one man
sin entered the world and death through
sin and thus death spread to all men
because all have sinned and then Romans
6:23 the wages of sin is death so we
find that death is the natural result of
the presence of sin and everyone dies uh
John 5 verse 22 and verse 28 and 29 uh
that uh Marvel not at this for the hours
coming in which all who are in the
graves will hear his voice well the word
there grave is described in the Old
Testament as she
and that's the place where you find
David died and was buried with his
father shol that is the grave then you
also have the the Dual application of
some of these words like um now gienna
the Lake of Fire Hades describes the
grave as well as the torment that will
come again in the end time you have to
look at the context though because a lot
of times people think that well you die
I was talking to someone recently they
saidwell don't all Wicked people die and
go to hell
uh or don't all righteous people die and
go to heaven no we're going to have
those appointments that's why John 5:28
and 29 says verse 29 and come forth they
that have done good to the resurrection
of Life they that have done evil to the
resurrection of condemnation or
damnation as the King James version says
so the reward is when the Lord comes
that's why Revelation 20:6 says blessed
and holy is he who has part in the first
resurrection over such the second death
has no power everyone experiences the
first death possibly but there will be
those that will be alive when Jesus is
Jesus returns so there'll be some who
will never experience the the first
death but they might experience the
second death if they have not received
Jesus now the second death doesn't mean
well you had the first one already the
second death is destruction eternally
being destroyed in the Lake of Fire not
Eternal fire but the impact of Eternal
fire which is meaning you are banished
never to exist again but hell uh was not
in the very beginning the word there in
the Book of Genesis talks about the
Earth was without form and void and
darkness moved upon the face of the deep
it was simply talking about the
Subterranean condition that God saw the
world in before he created it but it was
not hell first off I just want to say
that was a lot to say in three minutes
but that answer was very clear thank you
not didn't even mention tarus which is
the place of spirits where evil spirits
are strained from carrying out their
work where the Lord has been holding
Satan in check yeah that's a that's
where he was cast in Chains and
delivered in darkness wow that was a an
added bonus there bonus all right Daniel
if Enoch was close to God and God took
him into heaven why was The Book of
Enoch not included in the Bible this is
from Margaret out of Indiana all right
thank you Margaret and this is an
interesting question that I imagine some
people would never think to ask because
they have not heard of a Book of Enoch
so you would wonder why would that be in
the Bible Well it may interest you to
know that there is a real document
called The Book of Enoch there's
actually multiple books of Enoch and
you're probably referring to something
called first Enoch it is one of a number
of
pseudepigraphal writings that are
attributed to Enoch uh written sometime
about 3 or 400 years before Christ in
the the Greek period now pseudo piga is
a word pseudo means FAL false or
artificial or or spous and graffa graph
is writing so you have false writings
this would be like a literary hoax or a
forgery in other words something that's
written down with somebody else's name
on it because imagine you're writing
something and you want people to believe
it but they're not going to believe you
who are you and so you're going to put
somebody else's name on it they
certainly would believe this if I put uh
let's see Enoch his name he was close to
God he walked with God and what if Enoch
1500 years before the time of Moses
wrote the first things that ever got
written down and are included well that
would make it pretty special and so the
Book of Enoch is one of those types of
types of books a pseudepigrapha was
somebody else's name applied to it now
interestingly uh there is a line from
The Book of Enoch that is quoted by Jude
in the book of Jude chapter 1 the only
chapter verse 14 and 15 where he quotes
Enoch saying this behold the Lord comes
with 10,000s of his Saints to execute
judgment on all to convict all who are
ungodly among them of all their ungodly
Deeds which they have committed in an
ungodly way and of all the harsh things
which ungodly Sinners have been have
spoken against him so this uh affirms
Jesus coming in judgment I have to point
out here that uh Jude did not quote The
Book of Enoch he quoted words that are
also quoted in The Book of Enoch in
other words uh Jude through the
inspiration of the Holy Spirit affirms
what had been handed down through the
years and whoever wrote This Book of
Enoch and made up most of it they
actually included little bits and pieces
of Truth and this is one of those things
that through the the inspiration of the
Holy Spirit Jude knew that Enoch
actually said this and it was included
but by by quoting this he's not saying
that everything within the Book of Enoch
is inspired or holy or written by Enoch
there's actually other places in the New
Testament where there are sources
outside of the Bible that are also
quoted it doesn't mean that those
sources are all inspired and we should
trust everything that they say so yes
Enoch was close to God but the Book of
Enoch first Enoch was not written by him
whoever wrote wrote it included some of
those things that Enoch prophesied about
and God saw fit to include those parts
in the Bible that you and I have today
wow I knew that this was going to be a
learning experience pseudepigrapha
pseudo piga I I love that I love that
thank you that's your friends yes yes I
had to write that one down thank you
Pastor rery can you please explain
Isaiah chapter 27 verse 13 is it
connected to the sixth or seventh
trumpet of Revelation this is from Nancy
out of
Tennessee thank you Nancy I would say
yes and no Isaiah 2713 is not the actual
seventh trumpet
however the some of the language of
Isaiah 27 is very much connected to the
seventh trumpet how well let's read what
happens when the seventh trumpet is
sounded in Revelation
11: 14 and we'll just read verses 14
through 17 or 18 the second W was passed
and behold the third world comes quickly
verse 14 verse1 15 and the seventh angel
sounded and the was great voices in
heaven saying the kingdoms of this world
will become the kingdoms of our Lord and
of his Christ and he shall reign forever
and ever and the 4 and2 and the elders
fell down and on their faces they
worshiped God and they give gave thanks
to God and then in verse 18 and the
nations were angry and thy wrath is come
and the time of the Dead that they
should be judged and that thou should as
give reward into thy servants the
prophets and to the Saints and them
which Fear Thy Name small and great and
should destroy them which destroy the
Earth that's the language of the seventh
trumpet now let's compare that
description in Revelation 11
to the context of Isaiah chter 27 verse
one in that day the Lord with his sore
and great strong sword shall punish
Leviathan The Piercing serpent even
Leviathan that crooked Serpent and he
shall slay the dragon that is in the sea
all of that language symbolic language
is referring to Satan it's referring to
the same prophetic type of scenario that
we see in the Book of Revelation the
serpent the dragon the sea Etc and then
in verse five or let him take hold of my
strength that he may make peace with me
and he shall make peace with me speaking
of those who take a hold of the
righteousness of Christ and find peace
and forgiveness in Jesus Christ referred
to in Revelation 117 trumpet as the
Saints who inherit God's kingdom and
verse six he shall cause them to to come
out of Jacob and take root and Israel
shall Blossom blood and Bud and fill the
face of the world with fruit exactly
what we see in Revelation chapter 11 in
the seventh trumpet where the Saints
inherit the kingdom and then of course
verses 10 all the way down through
13 very much similar type of language to
what we see taking place in Revelation
11 so we see here some clear parallels
between Isaiah chapter 27 and the
seventh trumpet in Revelation 11 which
pronounces the coming of Christ the
establishment of his kingdom the
Judgment of the Nations the reward of
the Saints the the uh pronunciation of
judgment upon those who destroy the
Earth including of course Leviathan that
Great Serpent the devil and his angels
so there's definitely some parallelism
there though the representation is not
exactly the same in Isaiah chapter 27 we
might say that that Revelation 11 is
boring from Isaiah 27 and as it does
from much of the Old Testament when it
pulls together this conclusive
Revelation from Jesus Christ of events
that have transpired in our time now are
transpiring and are to transpire and
these are definitely events that are to
transpire so I hope that has been
helpful n see and answering your
question all right thank you for
shedding light on that pastor rafy
Pastor lomma Kang this comes from Tony
out of Canada he says No More Tears pain
and all things of sadness long gone will
we still have choices in the new Heaven
and new earth how will we prevent hearts
from being lifted up again thank you for
that question you know this question
comes up periodically and I did an
entire sermon at one of our past 3abn
camp meetings call Affliction will not
rise up a second time you want me to
check that on 3abn plus because I did a
six-page indepth sermon as to why the
Bible supports that there will be no
possibility of sin let me start with
those passages I'll give go ahead and
give you some very quickly the first one
which is the greatest assurance namam 1
19 he will make an utter end speaking
about Affliction Affliction shall not
rise up a second time now first of all
God said it
won't I'm simple enough to believe that
God said it won't what is the great
controversy all about the great
controversy about is about Sin being
completely permanently eternally
obliterated righteousness being
established permanently in
eternally uninterrupted but we have to
notice something let me just point this
out very quickly 1 John
3:2 this is a vitally important passage
beloved now we are children of God and
it has not yet been revealed what we
shall be but we know that when he is
revealed we shall be like him for we
shall see him as he is now let's let's
go back briefly we shall be like him how
is he here is what Jesus
said the prince of this world is coming
and he has nothing in me if we're going
to be like him the prince of this world
who at that time will be destroyed will
have nothing in us and here's the reason
why Revelation
22:1 he that is unjust let him be unjust
still he which is filthy let him be
filthy still he that is righteous let
him be righteous still he that is Holy
let him be holy still the word here that
I use is sealed we're going to be sealed
in they're going to be two conditions
people are going to be sealed in in
other words for the righteous no sin is
possible for the
righteous for the wicked no
righteousness is possible for the wicked
they're sealed in their condition did
you get that he that is unjust let him
be unjust still for both they Remain the
way that they are sealed in no more
righteousness for the wicked no more
wickedness for the righteous and here's
the reason why because we put on
incorruption 1 Corinthians chapter 15
this corruption this corruptible will
put on incorruption if you're
Incorruptible can you be corrupted no if
you're are Immortal can you be made
Mortal again no mortality means the
possibility of death but you are now
Immortal no possibility of death if
there's no possibility of death there's
no possibility of sin and finally in
heaven Revelation 21:
27 there shall in no wise enter into it
that is into heaven anything that
defiles and whatsoever worketh
Abomination or maketh a lie but they
which are written in the Lamb's Book of
Life how will you be uh how will you be
defiled if there's nothing in heaven to
defile you and you are Incorruptible so
my conclusion is we are righteous still
We Are Holy still and there's no
possibility and you can't choose sin
because there's no sin in heaven and
praise God for that what a wonderful
don't have a character of sin yeah you
have his charact we shall be like him
that was a great sermon I remember
cheering in my mind as you were
preaching that so what was it called
again Affliction shall not rise up a
second time great message amen amen I
want to give you another opportunity to
send your questions in text your
questions to us at 618 228 3975 again
that's 618 228 3975 or email them to
Bible QA at
3abn.org that's 3abn uncore official
Daniel how is country living connected
to the Three Angels messages where is it
spoken about in scripture and spirit of
Prophecy this is from a viewer out of
Tennessee all right thank you and I I
love living in the country because you
walk out your door and you're not
assaulted by sirens and and you know the
the the pollution of the air you get to
see the birds and I saw a skunk actually
this morning and it wasn't polluting it
was beautiful and I I feel like God
communicates with us in that area really
well let me make three points here
number one The Three Angels messages are
God's final warning and the first and
second angels message unite together in
the third Angel's message and they all
swell to a loud cry that then gives the
glory of God's presence through the
people who are filled with his presence
to the whole world and so the third
Angel's message then is the final
message that is given to a world that is
gripped in sin particularly aim to those
who want to be rescued to be pulled out
from the grip of sin so you got the
first Angel's message which lifts up
God's King om which says uh um fear God
and give glory to him for the hour of
his judgment has come worship Him who
created the Heaven the Earth the Sea and
the Springs of water he's our creator
he's our righteous judge and then the
second Angel's message demonstrates
Satan's kingdom says Fallen is Babylon
that great City because she made all the
the Nations drink of the wine of the
wrath of her fornication so you got the
two kingdoms and the third Angel's
message brings it to a conclusion make a
choice it's time to choose and so Point
number two is this that in that in that
time of choosing cities they may be
convenient but they are gathering places
of sinfulness that illustrate the
kingdom of Satan cities are full of
artificial Entertainment full of things
that exalt worldly and selfish pleasure
abundant crime and immort immorality and
also the availability of any evil for a
very very small price the fascination of
sin advertized on on almost every corner
the danger from violence uh cities being
a powder keg of contradictory viewpoints
ready to explode at any time and as you
look around at things that have happened
in the past we recognize yes there there
is conflict brewing and when people are
gathered together tightly that really
explodes pollution contagion of disease
the danger of collapsing Financial
networks in a food supply if the food
Supply runs out those in the city that's
going to cause some problems really
really quickly especially for certain
people who the government says no you're
last in lineer you're not in line at all
because you're not believing what the
world is supposed to believe right now
so let me get to Point number three and
that's that country living offers a way
to reach the cities with the third
Angel's message in a Godly way and
Country Living illustrates the kingdom
of God it's a healthy environment where
you can raise young men and women to
minister for God based on principle not
surrounded by not taking on the habits
of the Cities not dazzled by the
artificial City Life not living by the
same sinful standards pervading the
cities not participating in the same
destructive Lifestyles or not presenting
those sinful images and lifestyles in
addictions to the tender young eyes and
ears and mouths of children cities must
be worked but they have to be worked
from Outpost centers where people come
in to pull people out of the the grip of
sin now of course we have to have
churches in cities and Ministries to
people who live there but the
institutions of health and education and
and and administration need to be
outside those cities surrounded by God's
book of nature where he can easily use
what he's placed at our disposal to draw
people to the final message of choosing
and we're surrounded by that finally in
country locations you can grow your own
food which gives you a little more time
to minister when those Food Supplies and
financial networks are cut off because
and I got to say this you can go to the
country and bring the city with you all
right but we got to be preparing
spiritually and physically John the
Baptist lived in the country ministered
in uh to the cities Elijah lived in the
country ministered to the cities Jesus
did not have a home in the cities but he
ministered there and if you read closely
Paul ministered in the cities but he was
not a city dweller so God calls us to
share the message in the cities as much
as possible but uh if possible take your
kids especially outside where they can
grow strong like a good strong tree
planted by streams of water amen praise
God well said Daniel you know this the
country life has grown on me what you
Pastor Oh Yeah from Brooklyn to
Thompsonville well that's a big jump
yeah that's the passion of a dad with
children in the country that's
rightfully said live among the
skunks I'm glad you didn't get spray for
all of our sakes exactly oh but country
life is great you it gives you an
opportunity to connect really in nature
with God and and all of that we want to
be able to connect with you and go to
the Lord to together so we're going to
take a brief break we're going to share
with you how you can get in touch with
us how you can submit your questions and
uh then they can be answered on future
programs we'll be right back please
don't go anywhere there's a little bit
more to
come if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
light on those texts that seem difficult
to understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org answers from God's word where
did the time go I have no idea but I
want to take a moment to open up the
floor for any final thoughts that you
may have let's start with you Pastor
raffy yeah I just wanted to go back to
that last question from Nancy regarding
Isaiah 27 we didn't look at verse 13
that was the question she had and it
says there it shall come to pass in that
day that the great trumpet shall be
blown so there's the the question she
has about the trumpet being blown and
does it relate to Revelation 11 and the
seventh trumpet and notice what it goes
on to say and it and they shall come
which were ready to perish from the land
of Assyria from the outcast of the land
of Egypt and shall Worship the Lord in
the Holy Mountain at Jerusalem so
there's a definite connection here Nancy
between the seventh trumpet in
Revelation 11 and re and Isaiah 27:13
because this is talking about the
outcast it's talking about that
resurrection of the just it's talking
about those that are were ready to
perish that are coming back from the
land of Assyria and that the out crust
of Egypt and they're all going to work
Worship the Lord in the Holy Mount of
Jerusalem and that's the destination of
the Saints when the seventh trumpet is
sounded amen amen Pastor L you know this
thing about Sin possibly rising up again
I think that I want to encourage many of
you to do a forensic study on this topic
you know the beautiful thing about this
when I like the Bible says speaking
about how we are redeemed it says his
seed the seed of Christ remains in us
and we cannot sin amen and so the works
of the devil has not only led to the
destruction of the devil but also to the
destruction of his Works Peter says the
Earth also and the works that are
therein shall be burned up so the Lord
is going to extinguish this entire thing
get rid of all of sin and all of its
accruement and we'll have a kingdom
where only righteousness dwells amen
amen I want to thank you for joining us
Daniel thank you Pastor LMA Kang and
thank you Pastor rafy we want to thank
you for tuning in please make sure you
send us your questions we'd love to
answer them in future programs until
next time may God richly bless you amen
[Music]